[Applause]
all right so all right everybody don't
embarrass Gary because he's wearing that
being able said because because of the
the head lice but anyway don't say
bedbugs
oh jokes so the reason why this was a
very important panel to me because I
said earlier these two people have
actually impacted my life quite a bit
and the one thing I'm gonna say about
the Gary is that what Gary taught me and
I'm gonna I don't even know if carry
members that we met but I'm gonna ask
him what Gary taught what I realized
when I watched Gary was that there's a
lot of people and I came from the agency
side a lot of people that can come in
the room ago here's how you should do
your Instagram there you go oh my god
that sounds so smart how many followers
do you have to go I don't have any
followers but this is what I recommend
you ask Gary's like a million [ __ ] you
now what two million three million but
uh and so what it took away from me is
you you if you really want to understand
you have to be a true practitioner both
these men are practitioners and so when
I tell people text messaging is what I
believe in right now I didn't just say
that I wrote a book and put my phone
number on the cover so I could learn
gary told me look you're [ __ ] around
you better have video so I got a video
guy to follow me around so I can learn
what that was like you know and so at
the end of the day I think that that's
the one thing that I've taken away from
Gary which is if you really believe that
this is the thing go practice it so you
can learn that craft so you can be the
best at telling other people how to do
it Gary how do we meet I think we met at
a Pepsi meeting no [ __ ]
II don't uh you know where your first
secret wine party was here my suite in
the Hilton not true
no that was a second it wasn't the same
[ __ ] but you I was that the first time
we met in the Hilton you were walking
through the Hilton I hunted you down and
I was at Pepsi and I thought to myself I
wanted me Pepsi a digital leader and BR
is that digital leader I said I could
partner with Gary people would believe
that I was a digital leader too so I
could fake it until we made it and so
that's that's how we met I was Gary's
first corporate client we had 12 people
that's exactly right but no question I
think bonded a whole lot and PepsiCo
they took a shot at when we were super
ragtag other faces and good friends I
see took shots it with us early on and
those are the meaningful moments right
like for all of us no matter what we do
there's always gonna be a person that
gives you an at-bat so much of what
brings me happiness is good things have
happened to me which allows me to can I
can give more at-bats today than I
sometimes I can get more bats in a month
now than I used to be able to do in a
year and that's just how it works right
and I think that um especially when you
give without expectation it's been
something I've been spending a lot of
time with myself on trying to figure out
what makes me so happy and how do i
articulate that as a framework and I
think things that make me happy is like
random music during a tough
aniseh New Jersey makes me the happiest
so you can make that play the whole time
but I think I think I think no question
the thing that is really joking
it was comedy I think giving without
expectation right super big deal for
some we met he brought a bunch of
youngsters on his team I remember like
remember like yesterday I'm just a
remember when we met like yesterday I
think I think what really what what I
think about and I've already seen like
six or seven faces I can remember a lot
of those meetings and I know them like
when you default into giving without any
thought of what happens in return I'm
really fascinated by the practicality of
karma and I think that it's one of the
hardest core business principles and so
yeah I think that's what you guys and
some of the other people here did for me
and I I try to do for others I had an
interesting experience by the way this
conversation for me is always everybody
can talk about marketing in the industry
we can talk about that but for me it's
really like what what it takes to make
the person that you are is more
interesting to me but maybe because I
talked about that did you all the time
but what was interesting is I had an
interesting moment recently in my life
and this was like two weeks ago I was at
Michael's office and I said hey look I'm
doing this for that should I ask for
this and he said you know what you were
more of a statesman than that dude you
are more of a statesman and you don't
have to be got any kind of laid out to
me and I was and it's the same thing
which is and that's always how I live my
life which is Karma's much more
important than so what would you tell
the younger you Oh what would I tell you
well one start earlier you know believe
in yourself and start earlier any part
of that is and we are now in an age of
such extraordinary disruption where you
know the iconic players of yesteryear I
mean one of the things I think about a
little bit is for about a 50-year period
of time from 1940 to 1990 not much
happened right it was madman for that
entire period okay we invented at Xerox
machine big [ __ ] deal right dude you
know many pieces of my butt I mean
copies of my but that made theirs nasty
but the but but now big companies now
after you know 30 years of incredible
disruption big companies have figured it
out which is you know instead of status
quo of being the status quo changes now
the status quo they have in the
corporate suite come to the belief that
they've got to innovate and if that
wasn't true then you wouldn't have had
Unilever buying dollar sir dollar shave
for a billion dollars you wouldn't have
had when you got some now blocked by 300
but you know by Walmart so they're
convinced now that you know stand still
and you die you're got to be like a
short you've got to move forward and
they know they don't get it which is
amazing which is incredible concession
and Michael tomorrow on that point I
think we're in the middle right now
because I think they think they can
acquire it which is always what a banker
thinks they can do the problem is both
the companies you mentioned have
absolutely zero shot of success three
years from today they're already
finished yeah if you look at what's
happening with if you look at the
current state of both those companies
right this second the soul is gone the
people that drove it are just waiting
for their burnout and they're gonna
leave and the Machine doesn't know how
to take that organ in it and so what's
gonna be interesting to see is what
happens next
are we actually just at the end of those
companies because distribution in the
middle has been commoditized which was
always their advantage the economics or
will they start understanding how to
create Navy SEALs and Green Berets to go
along with their army navies and that's
what I'm fond of them as pirates but I
think yes I think it's the exact I think
there's two things so one is they're
gonna become distressed assets
potentially which you'll get bought by
guys like you which we've talked about a
lot or guys like Amazon the second piece
is what they don't realize is that
they're carrying legacy assets which is
Talent the sad thing is talent will be
the largest determinant of success by
2025
than anything else data energy it
doesn't matter but if you can't figure
out how to retrain your talent to be of
this generation you're done and that's
what they haven't been able to do that's
why they don't succeed what are you
gonna tell an old are you what is it old
are you gonna think about what what
you've done in your life what would I
hope the 84 year old version of me is
saying about me right now first of all
it's saying I don't have a shot in hell
of getting
no shot in hell it's because I think I'm
trying to like the same way blockchains
doing what it's doing to the Internet I
think I'm trying to do to heaven what
with my actions listen I think that um
don't even get that joke but yeah
blockchain I think I think I think I
think aetherium is super interesting um
I don't know
bonad I I would I'd like to think that
that version is is proud of the way I'm
conducting myself you know I I have
really big aspirations to be an all-time
entrepreneur I think that there are a
lot of people gonna make a lot more
money and make far more impactful
businesses than me but I think I'm up to
something with how many entrepreneurs
I'm impacting along the way I know um
giving up a lot of economics every year
which you know for that purpose and I
think that should play itself out nicely
it feels nice to live my life right now
getting 20 to 50 DMS or emails a day of
detailed 15 paragraph stories of how
this one video or the consistent
listening while they're running to the
podcast it's really it feels nice I got
a couple off the back of my book and
it's but it's a high that you can't
replicate it's funny to me it's me
getting an email like that or going
garage saleing and buying like a
Thundercat for a dollar that I know is
11 dollars on eBay
both those but I mean this this is
interesting both those things give me a
bigger high then landing a seven million
dollar client they just do and I think
all of us have those versions there's
things that you know excite you or make
you feel good that aren't necessarily
tied into the economics in the business
world that you're in and I think those
are things that we have to pay attention
to in 1999 I read Harvard Business
Review for the very first time I read a
quote in it and I have every single
print edition of Arbutus review since 99
I read a quote that said the mark of a
great leader is where your number two
goes to leave and so I took that away
which is always make the people who work
with you or around you better than you
and you know I think I like to think you
know the people who work for me that I
have a decent track record of doing that
but I have a really important question
if he buys the Jets can we buy the
Giants ah
I'd be good mix a green at all times I
love mark [ __ ] gasps now did I do so
in kind of that vein
Michael so your organisation's expanding
I've watched this man's organization
expand it can't just be about you so how
do you make sure that I have an idea how
many kids do you have Michael got six
Michael's got six kids and they range
from 32 to 20 months actually before
before I before I actually asked the
question about culture and how you keep
the culture in your organization I do
want to talk so what's the what's the
legacy because you're a very very
personal guy and I know you're I'm gonna
ask you this table what's the legacy you
do want to leave your kids or well I so
when I am asked that question but not
even legacy like acids but like you got
it you'll tell me if you're on the
status right with you okay
but what what I what I want to do is I
want to prove
Keats wrong right so Keats said our
names are written water right so like
this I want to build in a legacy I want
to have is gonna be enduring I want
somebody like you want right to you know
somebody to point to me and said I've
learned something from that guy or he
built something right or he changed
something you made things better and you
know and I want that to be remembered
you know not just like Michael Morial
service but you know for a decade or a
century after that so that's awesome
what I wanna do Gary I know you're very
personal I will not ask enough family
but I just want to know as a father like
what do you want them to take away from
your life you know I I hope that they
say debt you know dad felt so much guilt
that Grandma and Grandpa put him in such
a good position to succeed that he did
the same for us out of a payback for
them
Maya know and they they let you live
tulay for the rest of your years yeah I
mean look to me to me I am I am
perfectly parented I really believe that
which is a very I mean it which is a
very you know I'm driven by gratitude
and guilt I'm very aware that that what
they did was so all time that I feel a
sense of giving back so much so that's
not just to my children I'm trying to
you know use modern technology and
communication to give back as a whole I
was really put on by really special
parents and put me in a real position to
succeed at the face of what was
politically correct at the time you know
I'm an immigrant who in the 80s and 90s
every Russian kid that came over during
that time with my parents education was
the way out right we are all poor we all
lived in studios education was the way
out and my mom created air cover for me
to be an entrepreneur when the word
didn't exist and I'm unbelievably
grateful to for that and so I just want
my kids to feel like I put them in a
position to succeed I don't want them to
be entrepreneurs I don't want them to be
anything other than whatever makes them
feel the way I feel about my game I want
to support that and I think the greatest
mistake in our society right now is that
parents feel that children are a a
product or an indicator of who they are
which allows them to manifest their
insecurities under children I want to do
the reverse of that I want to put them
in a position to succeed
I've known this man for a long time and
had some grown-up [ __ ] okay
so so to that and then I'm gonna I
started out to Michael but Mike we're
gonna come back up not scary
you've had I've met you you had 12
people how many have now
850 850 how many offices four four
offices so it can't just be about
garroting although your names on the
door how do you make sure really fit on
the door yeah both your names on the
door by the way but but he's got his
wife stigma Chuck yeah what uh how do
you how do you ensure that the people
who come into that organization knew
understand what you were trying to build
or are building I think um and it's hard
everything anything great is hard I
think I think there's two things I think
they pop they pull from opposite
directions when you ask that question
the first thing that runs through my
mind is moldable dictatorship right
there's just four or five things that I
believe in tremendously so you
definitely are Russian yeah you know you
know I think it's super important to
know what your three or four religions
are right empathy you know you know
really matters to me attention really
matters to me the current state of
culture really matters and we have to
create that way we have to strategize
that way but you know if you bring up
like fifteen or twenty direct reports a
lot of them will talk if Ryan Harwood I
bought pure well last year if he came up
here's like I didn't talk to Gary the
first six months you know I I tend to be
you know I tend to be very hands-off
other than if people are to me the key
things are are you trying to succeed by
tearing everybody else down versus just
building the biggest building that to me
is like something I really spend a lot
of time on look managers by nature don't
have the luxury that the person that has
the name on the door has which is I'm
the logo I have no vested interest if my
CFO is right or the entry-level
accountants right my my vested interest
is that the logo is right so I'm able to
be agnostic for a manager there's a lot
of people who live their lives that when
they hit three hundred fifteen thousand
dollars a year
a real Mitzvah like they made it like
that's what they want and what happens
is they switch into defense they were on
offense their whole life until they got
to the point where the work-life balance
and the money and what other variables
in their lives it's set and then they go
on defense and what they're doing is
they're suppressing anybody who wants to
encroach on their territory which
naturally are the people that work for
them and I spend an ungodly amount of
time paying attention to that dynamic
everything else I feel comfortable with
at this point in my life I now feel
confident in my intuitive understanding
of human behavior and how it impacts
communication and products so I'm gonna
continue to bet on that skill and that
will lead us in the right direction
voice a rml whatever it may be next you
know what I told about textures like now
it's not that big now he's like text me
please
good thing I record everything we'll see
all right I think I think that um I bet
so that's when I spent a lot of time
thinking about empowering them to no end
while making them accountable for two to
four things that really matter at the
end of the day I spent a lot of time
thinking about being inside of large
organizations and the problem is their
pyramids by nature are built to create
that situation but I always used to tell
my team is that
so even when I you know almost poach to
go work someplace else for Mondelez I
could have said give me the person when
they asked what do I want to stay I
could have said give me somebody else's
role but instead I said let's increase
the pyramid commerce and then we have we
put a hundred new people underneath the
e-commerce job that's very hard because
everybody thinks that getting to the top
you have to step on the person above and
so culture how do you maintain well I
does Gary was talking a kind of an
expression that I had or philosophy that
I had and I didn't invent it but I think
it's very true which apropos to exactly
what you're saying a people hire a
people and B people hire C people and a
people hire a people because a people
says oh my god if I hire somebody better
they're just gonna create opportunities
for me I am totally secure in my skill I
can quit my job and get rehired anytime
but they feel fine about that it only
they know that only makes them better B
people it's all about preservation the
preservation
that you talked about and they have to
hire cease because they gotta be smarter
and better than the seas because that's
how they assure their own preservation
in the pyramid that you're talking about
I think that the new workplace and the
workplace that you have the workplace
that I have are kind of different people
work in teams it sounds like you're the
type of manager that I also try to be
which is just walk around you talk to
anybody in your organization you put up
their feet your your feet on their desk
and you say what's going on tell me
what's going on what are the three
things going bump in the night
you know and you know it's if you have a
traditional organization that just
drives them nuts it's what are you
talking you're talking to one of my
people why are you doing you can talk to
me about that and it's like yeah I can
but I want to get their point of view
so that has follow me around the A's and
A's and B's and C's and always try to
hire A's the tragedy is you know at
different times and this was your point
and a becomes a B and that becomes very
hard because when they reach that you
know that's whatever that number is and
all of a sudden it becomes it moves from
advancement and expansion and generosity
to preservation and when it does that
then it's really problematic and it just
happens and it's sometimes kind of with
tragic results like I'm building a
business all of a sudden it becomes
really big
I'd love to push that person up but all
of a sudden that a became a B you know
what's interesting about that is we've
been spending a lot of time on and I did
this kind of anecdotal it's fun to have
some of the faces in this room I always
thought if somebody wasn't gonna be in
my organization anymore I appreciated
them being in the organization so much
that I want to do anything I could to
help them in next chapter we're taking
it so extreme that we're creating an
internal job board because right now
where I'm sitting in the world so many
people are asking me for help to fur
they're hiring and I what you were
talking I said yeah one of the I'm sorry
I'm about to go around little bits my oh
my brain works the reason I was starting
to tell you this is when he was talking
the thing that happens is unless you're
able to
grow the business at a rapid pace you
keep you stuck you have moments where
you can't feed all the A's and so like
sometimes they tap out
but sometimes the company taps out and
it can't feed everybody and that also
creates a scenario one of the things
that's happening for me is because we've
been marketing slightly different than a
lot of people and that is now becoming a
little bit more of the accepted practice
we have a lot of talent and and a lot of
C's are starting to think and our B's a
lot of these are starting to think and
are becoming A's and I can't feed all of
them at the speed at which they're
growing in comparison to how the overall
company is growing so so that everybody
wins I'm spending a lot of time thinking
about what would it mean if I take real
talent and how do you get people
comfortable to raise their hand and said
yeah I do want to be the CMO of that
startup or I do want to go client-side
and work at Mondelez it's scary right
because if they don't get the job then
they think they put themselves in a
vulnerable position I think the thing I
spend a lot of time on is how do i limb
innate cynicism within the organization
and that's very very difficult
I mean people when they leave Vayner I
try to meet with them and I just had
somebody who left after four years just
got to that place and she said literally
the entire 15 minute she's like I don't
understand why I didn't come to you when
you've done everything to create a
scenario where you want me to come to
you my co-workers came to you like I am
not that kind of person so and I'm
empathetic to that I don't like to go to
people either so it's just a constant
battle you're always battling at scale
and that's what that's what's very lucky
that we have expansive organizations
right you went from 12 to 80
we're 850 I'm sorry 850 I'm into 8850
and I guess I prefer so anyway but
whatever it is it's the same [ __ ] very
very very rapid expansion so you can you
know you can please take it you can feed
you can feed and if you can't feed it's
problematic I want to come back to and
don't let me forget this finished out
but I want to say one thing about
raising capital versus making money
around feeding but go ahead I don't want
forget this we yeah there's so many
interesting topics we can talk about
including the whole venture thing which
is yep right exactly see that well I
thought it was Michael Jordan next to me
for a second I actually think you guys
have not spend enough time talking about
we just haven't seen yet
you have another because I think he's
got an interesting model what are you
gonna say well okay so what I was
because you talked about big companies
and buying right buying and then once
they bought that transplanted tissue
right gets rejected by the body and that
we have seen that sad story over and
over and over again and it's it's almost
that the flip of that that it actually
works and it's integrated as a rarity
but there is a reason a longtime reason
why big companies don't experiment and
try to buy the winners and it's because
you know the drumbeat of earnings
releases every three months if you're a
public company you cannot afford
draining blood out of the system to make
an investment in something new
particularly when you know it has a high
failure rate venture will tell you the
venture guys will tell you to in 10 are
about the odds the shareholders would go
nuts they would say what you make 80%
failure right why are you doing that
right and you can't just take a bunch of
money out of earnings and put it into
something and then we get to the problem
of you don't have anybody in your
organization because it's been a pyramid
for so long that really can take a risk
and invent because there are more bees
than A's and they're really into
preservation as opposed to invention so
they wouldn't take that risk to begin
with but the other bias of that is when
you buy a company when you buy a company
it is not it is it is not an impairment
to your profits it goes on your balance
sheet as an asset so there is a
technical bias to buy not build and so
that is one of the reasons I think on a
DNA level institutional level why big
companies cannot invent and it's more
than just they don't have a talent it's
a structure Wall Street has created a
scenario where these come these are no
longer companies their financial
arbitrage machines so they are and then
they have jockeys that ride the horse as
long as they can and you
and well be sessions on their
self-interest on the way out because you
know they used to call Time Inc it used
to because it was time life the time of
your life building and that is because
you know you just work there long enough
you retired between 55 and 60 you're a
millionaire guaranteed millionaire
comfortable retirement that's all that
you had to do so the name of the game
was don't screw up right you would say
that don't [ __ ] up anyway don't screw up
just don't don't you know I didn't
listen I got fired but anyway just don't
get fired
worked out work that okay but anyhow
ya know III but I the other thing that's
sad about it is that the scale of those
organizations can actually change that
dynamic from to intend to potentially
six and ten but yet there there's not
room for that because the leadership has
never seen what the failures of those
small businesses are to understand how
large-scale organizations can fix those
and one of it is just distribution and
access so like if we had what I tried to
buy the first receipt scanning platform
and I said to the organization it was a
distress task that it was twelve million
dollars I said look we're gonna make
this a de facto standard we're gonna put
on every single one of our packaging and
I said yeah but none of our competitors
are gonna use us I don't care about our
competitors there's 1,200 categories in
a grocery store
we represent ten of them and those tank
all the rest of the categories of but
we're the only people who can get it to
scale fast enough but they couldn't see
their way out of yeah now imagine if we
had owned check out this was before
check out fifty one before all those
magic we had owned or I tried to sell
him animal crackers but we had a two
hundred fifty million dollar movie deal
animal crackers a twenty million dollar
business twenty million dollar business
we didn't care who fell off the truck
but yet we could double it triple it and
then we had a movie deal and they were
like we don't see the economics I was
like oh my god you're killing why do I
have to do so right well nobody but this
this man is incredibly rare because he
was a rebel inside of a very giant
business and he actually succeeded some
days some days I'm talking about the
failures ever just say no but I mean I
mean but but it was an incredible I mean
you spent and I mean imagine all the
energy that you spent instead of
fighting your own organization to like
inventing right it was probably three
quarters or
90% fighting your own organization
saying I can't do this it's like what
it's a word what do you mean what are
you talking about
anyway what it's that's that's where you
guys cross paths right you guys have
similarities than that yeah that's true
we started with big companies and try to
try to reinvent them there is a book
before I loses thought called creative
destruction by a guy named Richard
Foster a McKinsey guy it is supposed to
be a manual right for big companies of
how to reinvent but when you read it it
becomes very clear that they're screwed
and forget it it can't happen it is
example after example of how they are so
lame when it comes to invention and he
gives many many great illustrations of
that but you have to ask yourself the
question why you know when all of a
sudden we went from oil lamps used to be
whale oil
right that's what lit every city and all
of a sudden became oil but all the
actors that were in whale oil none of
them went into oil oil the wagons that
won the West the Canastota wagons right
why didn't that become Fisher Body in
General Motors they just didn't and why
you know right why now you know that it
does take a musk right to bring the
brand-new automobile when these big
manufacturers are not leading they're
following and it has to do to the fact
that it becomes you know if you remember
Shawshank Redemption that talks about
being institutionalized they all become
institutionalized front-to-back all the
organization every piece of capital and
infrastructure and skill base is built
for this machine and nobody elevates it
to 35,000 feet to ask what business that
were in so no longer no longer
incentivize I do but why did Amazon
invent Amazon right you would think
right why didn't Kroger invent Amazon
right why we're lords and nobles why
didn't they're like oh shoot at that
happen
it's alright barn I'll be back damn well
you know it actually the first step is
denial nobody's gonna buy a book that
way when I took econ me too there
anybody ever gonna really buy an Oreo
online I was like oh my god yeah
meanwhile 55 to 265 so literally five
years before Google okay
Time Inc invented the first Google and
was called Pathfinder right except the
mistake was that the only fact you could
find out was contained in Time Inc
titles and the thinking was well [ __ ] if
it's not in the timing title it's not
you know not to do anything outside so
it's like a snooze so it failed
miserably right but the idea is that the
people in this room are the people are
gonna realize the future if you look at
this country and we're all here because
we love this country if you look at this
country and you look at some of the
great great great companies they you
know the Facebook's the Amazons you know
they're from here right and it's because
we are you know very adaptable and we
were all capable of this reinvention
creative thinking and I guess I'll end
no no we're not ending well my pits just
by saying that you know being an
entrepreneur is the hardest bravest
thing that anybody can do and you've got
to be you can't do it well unless you
are all in all in or or or you're all
out no I mean or or you're capable of
dealing with other people's opinions the
reason people struggle is because when
you're an entrepreneur it's really fun
to work somewhere right when you work
somewhere when something goes wrong
including if you get fired you blame
your boss my boss [ __ ] me right like
like like like entrepreneurship if
occult because there's no wiggle room
out you [ __ ] up
like everything that's wrong in my
company is 100% my fault
like every sin there's hundreds of
issues right now I hired the head of
that department I created that process
like everything runs through me and I
think people struggle with
entrepreneurship more because they're
worried about the
judgment and you've got to be able to be
numb to that feedback and that is not
most people's makeup yeah no I agree
with that I'm learning that to be honest
and and Bannen I think the thing that's
happening one thing that everybody here
has to understand is like look we've
lived through eight or nine years now of
economic prosperity there's a fuckload
of people running around this town right
now that think they're special they've
never made money any month they've run
their company they've lost money every
day like like people cheer raising
capital you gave up a piece of your
business so so Gary I'm gonna ask you
questions sure so there was something
like 160 plus or minus unicorns minted
last year right well hold it okay how
many of those right how many of those
will be around three years five years
and how many of those founders right one
billion dollars of the valuation of this
company how many of those founders right
are gonna walk away with them meaningful
anomaly uh probably ten to twenty
percent will be around and do their
thing and eighty to ninety percent of
the founders will leave with meaningful
money with meaning well yeah of those
ten or twenty yeah because once they get
nothing whatever those ten or twenty but
here's the important but here's my point
everyone make sure that reading
basically I think ninety percent of the
160 right now are gonna lead with
meaningful money
really I don't yeah so well first of all
it might just be we have a different
different definition of meaningful money
in might I know Mike I mean I mean that
meaning I think there's somebody who
runs a company and is extremely good at
raising capital for a company that
eventually goes belly-up but she or he
is able in Series C and D to take home
ten to thirty million dollars and take
it home is meaningful money for
something that ended up being a house of
cards okay your my definition and yours
are there for me but the reason why I
answer that as you know ten to thirty is
one to three percent of the whole
shooting match right I mean these are
companies worth a billion plus but we do
agree on this which is most of them will
just go puff right so think about that
they have been exalted by the press
right
160 unicorns right unicorns and they're
gonna you know billion dollar-plus and
the bulk of them are house of cards the
bulk of them have never made money the
bulk of them are really product of
financial engineering and good
salesmanship and by the way a financial
community community that has more money
than it has either brains or deal flow
and there's there's too much money in
the system guys how do you feel about
venture guys first of all can I just
tell you me Gary this is this would be
the fifth year that we've done this
everybody who I put between us gets
chewed up my god docile I've ever I'm
like oh my god it's working so I brought
the big gun I was like ah put Michael
right in front I think how do you feel
about venture look the biggest financial
loss in my career personally was 15
months ago or so when I decided to not
close out the fun that I was raising and
give back everybody's capital yet I was
carrying the talent and anticipating the
2% management fee on 150 million dollar
fund and took a complete bloodbath and
and I do think ten million dollars is
meaningful money and like and so like
I'm not I'm not you know I came from
zero so when you come from zero losing
seven figures out of being Noble feels
really [ __ ] up and so it's the most
proud I've ever been in my life and it
happened because as I was raising this
fund yeah I just woke up one morning and
said holy [ __ ] I don't believe in this
game right now and so what am I gonna do
lose cuz cuz I you know it's funny
losing that money was really smart
because I knew I know myself which is if
I ran that fund and that money got lost
and it would have because if you don't
believe in something completely you're
now guessing the reason I've been good I
don't predict you know like people he
predicted [ __ ] I don't predict anything
I [ __ ] execute early and then I
communicate about it
and so I don't guess and so like for me
when I don't guess I'm investing in
Facebook and Twitter and Tumblr like I
did early on and when I'm guessing I
looked more like the investor I was on
the back half and I just knew that [ __ ]
is [ __ ] up I'm very down
right now I have not invested
meaningfully now for two years I'm
really struggling with it I will get
back in the game because I genuinely
believe in voice and I will absolutely
bet on apps built on top of Google home
and amaz and Alexa so I'm excited it's
the first time I'm kind of feeling like
I'll get back in the game because I've
seen this rodeo before right because
these are apps on top of a device that
will matter
you know Spotify and and and ways and
Instagram these are apps on the iPhone
and so I'm excited about that but how do
I feel I feel very negative about it I
think there's a bunch of B and C and D
and EEF players who think they're
entrepreneurs and all time entrepreneurs
because it's cool we put on a pedestal
I think people raising a bunch of
capital and burning cash have no idea
what the [ __ ] they're doing our building
actual businesses are building on top of
platforms that have all the leverage
they have none and it's a and I'm just
not into it and I can't wait for [ __ ] to
hit the fan and carnage and blood
because and I mean it and I mean it
here's why because in the game of
business merit should prevail like you
shouldn't win if you suck so everybody
who's rolling around was screwed and so
everybody who's rolling around with a
t-shirt of their startup and think
they're special and are and are really
pumped about like you know like I raised
like guys listen to the conversations
you know every conversations am I raised
I raise this I raise that alive children
you know what I mean you know but it's
interesting because so so just so you
know Michael came from zero got fired
you have to pay check in his pocket and
built this business brick by brick well
what were the things that kept you up in
the night when trying to build a real
business versus so the biggest thing
that you hear in the venture
conversations is the most amount of time
and you talk about this to that as
founder will spend his raising money
versus building a businesses you say
that's to me all the time and the reason
why he built the incubator he has today
is because he doesn't want the founder
to spend time raising money he doesn't
think that that's important money is
easy
businesses are what's hard and so just
talk about I feel like that ethos built
first of all one thing I think one
earmark of an entrepreneur is the fact
that you know
you grew up really hungry and like a
bunch of realist all three of us did
that real [ __ ] hungry my oh my god I
know Phil start I'm Bonnie you just said
we were old earlier you know the very
things we can talk about but the I think
one of the more important things about
being an entrepreneur is having a North
Star because if you are in the weeds
rich said that to me the other day two
rich Dennis yeah so if you don't know
your finish line that's right we do you
have a pin because in the day to day
right in the battlefield day to day you
know
well sorts that ugly things happen and
if you don't have a 35,000 feet view you
will you know your compass will you'll
just be lost because if you if you soak
up every day you're gonna have some
victories and oh my god you're gonna
have three defeats in a row and I'd love
you love micro defeats do I love Mike
you know when I love I love being what
Edison said right you remember oh no you
know okay Edison said only old enough to
remember at me we're powered by the way
we hung out new jersey was good so but
what he said was I never failed
I learned 10,000 ways how not to make a
light bulb and that's what I think
exactly what you're getting at
micro defeats yes you've got to they're
not defeats their learning opportunities
and we talk all the time about quality
at-bats right you can strike out but of
quality what I demand is a quality
at-bat right I think Michael I think the
problem there is too many people in this
room and in this game are looking for
the short term economics yeah right like
I mean you know back to you have time I
think the reason people struggle with
micro defeat is because they're looking
to do it so fast the amount of 20 year
olds who think by 30 they have their
multi-million dollar thing you know you
just see it in people's behaviors you
take shortcuts and then when you're
taking shortcuts you make fatal flaws
not short-term flaws and that is by the
way one of the things you know we have
an internship program and everybody
there wants to be you know on
entrepreneur and we kind of say okay
let's level set number one this is not
college
right when you're in college you're a
customer you're not a customer okay
everybody here has their hair on fire
and the answer to whatever they want if
they say get me coffee the answer's yes
don't say wait a minute I didn't spend
seventy thousand dollars a year to go to
Yale right to get somebody up I mean
[ __ ] you right I mean you know we need
coffee right now why we're gonna be
working for the next 23 hours straight
so the so number one you're not a
customer anymore
right and number two they do have this
visual that they come up with an idea on
Monday on Tuesday they raise capital on
Wednesday the you know they got the NVP
on Thursday somebody buys it for a
business for a billion and on Friday
they're in San Tropez and you just got a
disabuse them of that and because that's
just not how it works it's it's a lot of
hard work it's you know from the banks
yeah it takes to make it like we get
into the central pan well you have ups
entropy so wait it's interesting because
rich Dennis who sundial I was the chief
growth officer for a year they just sold
to Unilever a little under a billion
everybody's like oh my god rich duh oh
it's amazing I can't believe you've done
to the guy and when you talk it was 26
years the man started selling soap on
the core first of all he escaped to
revolutions they had to get his family
out as refugees he learned out an accent
for Africa from an hour not revolutions
here learn how to make soap from this
yeah they live 12 people in a
three-bedroom apartment learned how to
make soap from his grandmother used to
sell in the village and started selling
bars of soap on the corner in Harlem
dude like and then to cut to have a 300
million dollar largest natural beauty
business and then to sell it I mean
you're just like that but Gary I've
watched you I watched you for two years
but I watched you do and that's what
people don't understand Gary came to me
in 12 people 30 60 and he was like okay
what's that what is what a big agencies
look like and we had a heart-to-heart
and I was like well here's what I know
of did it it was interesting to watch
every single move that Gary wins losses
RER cute acting shifting and Gary still
gets I put the beauty business in his
business and when I saw some of the
things I didn't like
he still gets a earful from me unlike
this is my Marcus gets a earful from me
all day long
Tregs I know I could get him on the
phone so but yeah I think that people
underestimate how long how long it takes
we're gonna take two questions so people
get ready yeah and we're gonna show let
me just say this I think I think advice
is interesting I think I think always
that matters more when the person that's
giving it to you actually lived it you
know the thing that I get razzed for the
most on the Internet happens to be the
thing I'm single most proud of which is
I entered my family business right and
so like a lot of people when I put out
content will say well why do you listen
to him like his family put him on I went
into my family business which was remote
but but it's even better and I've never
done do you know I'm not even sure if
you know this I've only started talking
about it for the last six months it
you've been too busy for me so let me
let me let me say this it's easy for me
to give advice to people to be patient
because my true life story was at 22
years old I went into my family business
I took my family business from a three
to a sixty million dollar business
I owned zero percent of that business I
never got paid over $100,000 because it
was a family immigrant school business
and when I left the 34 and started
vaynermedia the reason we were so humble
and started in buddy media's [ __ ]
conference room you would think somebody
who built a sixty million dollars
I left that business at 34 years old had
no money and no equity to my name
because the business was completely
owned by my dad cuz I'm part of an
immigrant family business and you go in
you build it for your family and a lot
of them end up the dad leaves and you
take it I had a different path so here I
am at 34 for all you 20 year olds zero
to my name right never got paid a
hundred thousand a year and had the chip
on my shoulder that I actually built
something from three to sixty me
I built it and left with nothing that's
so you know like so I started you loved
your parents like I like on it but it's
you know Michael it's important that's
the best thing I ever did I paid them
back for all the amazing things they did
that feels real whole for me but but you
know like people are just so impatient I
know he started it then and I had a
grind then and I had a scratch then and
so and I've done a whole lot in eight
years cuz I learned
in those years that I was running you
could do a lot of listen a lot more of
your stuff you know stuff happens later
in people why didn't you start really
getting like wait 30 days when it's not
tomorrow and it's the late 30s on the
experience of 20 years or 1518 years of
good execution right and then you could
start saying obnoxious [ __ ] like 10
million dollars isn't meaningful money
Carlos go ahead you know look you mean
from the perspective of being a mentor
or having one having one look I think
everybody does it different right like I
I will tell you flat-out I've never had
a mentor not even my dad right like I'm
an inside guy I'm in my own [ __ ] but I
don't think that's cool I don't think I
said yeah I think it's a flaw if you
want to be frank every time I've been
open to your [ __ ] I'm like oh that
helped me and like like it's just not my
natural being I think the value of
mentorship actually has much more Carlos
to do with the individual right like
I've watched you from afar for a while
you pick up things from other people and
you bet like everybody's different I
think the key is self-awareness the key
here is self-awareness who the [ __ ] are
you and how do you learn I knew how I
wanted to buy the New York Jets it was
by buying nostalgic brands and flipping
them I knew that I had to eat [ __ ] for
10 to 20 years of running an agency to
learn all this [ __ ] now I know what to
do but ten years ago my thesis was right
I could have gotten the capital I could
have done it but I didn't know I needed
the way I learned is by bleeding we
talked to the right trying to get you to
buy love root beer that's that's right
that's how I learn I need the taste so I
don't need a mentor because somebody
telling me something is why I got these
an deaths I need to just go in and taste
other people really get value out of
mentors I watch people I give them one
piece of advice and like how the [ __ ]
did they run with that [ __ ] and do up
you know you know so I think I think
self-aware if I could give everybody
here besides health besides health its
self-awareness cuz once you have that
unlock and you stop bullshitting
yourself of what you want to be versus
who you actually are [ __ ] starts
changing
yeah okay another God just shout it out
quit your job I can answer it while
you're thinking about it I think the
worst is slower and less I think the
worst I think the worst advice I give is
when I make it through the eyes and ears
and filter of who I am as a person I
think too way too many people give
advice predicated on themselves a lot of
the things I look for our themes and but
I spend a lot more time looking at the
collective than myself because there's a
lot of nuances about me that doesn't map
for other people so I think way too many
people's advice is to singular and they
and they don't have empathy to
understand the subtleties of everybody
else around them I think it's
interesting Gary said that he's in
himself I ran into Gary in Turks and
Caicos in a random random situation and
Gary had just stacks of books he was
like phone is off it's me family and
like this introspective moment to read
that you were reading Steve Jobs that
time it was really really interesting
insight does a very personal person but
I don't think people know because you're
so outward right wife you ever gave so
I'm gonna restate the question a little
bit when do I give the worst advice and
when I give the worst advice is when I'm
trying to be nice
alright when I'm trying to be polite
which comes super not natural to you
it's true it's true but you know
basically the worst advice is when you
when you read the you know the other you
know the person on the other side and
you tell them what they want to hear
says sometimes - the truth is tough and
sometimes you just feel like you got to
do that but yes it's when you when you
tell them what they want to hear and not
what is real like that I'm gonna take
two more questions cuz this feels to me
like one of the most truthful panels
that you're gonna see at South by
Southwest and I'm very excited about it
personally so two more questions I know
brother Rock
more questions or that's it we're gonna
shut it down if not all right thank you
in the back just yell from my standpoint
I think it's insane to pander to the
current state of political correctness
around parenting because it evolves
every 10 to 15 years based on our
overreaction one way or the other I
think we beat ourselves up too much I
handle it super well I know what my
intent is I [ __ ] love my children but
I can't love anybody if I don't love my
life and so I'm willing to be selfish to
be selfless
I'm also the byproduct it's very
individual I'm not gonna I could never
think to give somebody advice on raising
their kids or running their family no
but none of us know what's going on in
somebody else's [ __ ] home you don't
know how well it's working for me you
don't know how my wife and I were
brought up why that works for us because
we're used to it and it's our
conditioning you don't know that so cool
you want to tell me like cuz you feel
good about yourself coming home at five
but meanwhile you're on your phone the
whole time like the judgment of other
people's parenting is asinine I handle
it super [ __ ] easy Michael all right
maybe we should ask Katie
work-life balance I think number one you
got to love what you do right so if you
love would you do if that's if you love
what you do it all kind of blends
together for one thing you're you know
comfortable within yourself you're a
satisfied person that's by the way what
makes you a great parent is not coming
home and being a son of a [ __ ] because
you're pissed off of what you did for
the last you know 12 hours so I think
that if you love what you do then you
know you're kind of a satisfied content
person then it just works you know it
works itself out go just real quick he
gave more than he took oh my god
I actually it's so interesting you said
that you're just an interesting guy man
we should hang out more often but yeah
but you can't speak first because anyway
it's my deal yeah but one time I felt
that in one of our exits somebody
benefited more than I thought they
deserved and my partner brought me back
and said you know what if your tombstone
reads here lies Michael Obie gave too
many people too much you want that and I
said you know what I could live with
that
that's all it works all right block or
not block chain
I'm extremely bullish I think that it's
an obvious technology but I think
there's a bunch of [ __ ] losers in it
right now and it's early as [ __ ] so it
reminds me very early internet there's a
bunch of club promoters and huxter's and
real estate agents and social media
experts them but but that's exactly what
happens when new kid happens when I was
in the yesterday I was in I was like
this is exactly like the early internet
wait a second this and that's what [ __ ]
with smart people they see the people
associated with them and they're not
smart they think that is what represents
it and that's why they underestimate it
but the technology is black and white it
is a meaningful technology is it so so
basically you're watching you're talking
about the offensive line for the Jets
right yeah I know it's very very
important luck is it about luck or not
well part of it is for sure but they say
that what's the expression that not that
you make your own luck but that
preparation math yeah yeah that's right
what is it you're younger yeah that's
right is long your goobers said to me
miracles happen to everybody you just
need to be prepared to accept yeah I
think I think luck is an interesting one
for me have a little bit of a different
take I'm curious in the context that it
comes out of somebody's mouth so I
believe in chance and all these many
things and luck what-have-you but I
think that most of the time when
somebody spits that word it's because
they're not in a happy place with
themselves and they're trying to justify
why somebody else got something we we
very much struggle with with
responsibility and taking on
responsibilities and we like to pass it
on to somebody else and we're trying to
justify why we're not winning and we
like to throw that without words being
thrown around by a bunch of [ __ ]
losers to try to make themselves feel
better when when I misunderstood you in
the beginning when I think you and I
would both describe ourselves as lucky
sure right and but when you assign that
to somebody else like he was successful
because he got lucky that is what losers
judge judgment some real mistake it's a
real mistake and we're all doing it at
scale right now and it's really a
mistake you're just you're deploying it
like I think you know it's back for that
mentor question I really am trying to
figure out how people how to allow
people to start really thinking just as
much as possible inside their own frame
because envy and judgment
it's just brief like putting any energy
like I only want all of you to win
there's so much abundance of you wants a
couple of points so vision no I want to
zero
uh-uh what I what I actually want is to
figure out if I'm better than you on
merit like I want all of you to win I
want to win more than all of you I
genuinely think I will I mean it I mean
it but but what if I don't but if I
don't I'm pumped right I'm like you
[ __ ] earned it you won all right last
words nice words oh my god that sounds
so last piece of advice last piece of
advice last piece of advice is I've
never seen a period of such wrenching
change me and L me and Edison used to
talk about this by the way anyway
but such wrenching change and you guys
everybody in this room you're gonna
Herald that change it requires a great
deal of conviction and courage you've
got to again have a North Star to guide
you in other words the speed bumps of
every day can be a little deflating but
you can't let that damage your spirit
surround yourself with great people we
talked a little bit about advice the
interesting thing about advice don't
listen to anyone voice gather a lot and
then kind of tease out for that the
really interesting opinions and but do
it does take a village
be generous pay it forward all the time
and create that community and the only
one way to do that you know look if
you're an [ __ ] you're not going to be
able to do that everybody's going to
figure that out you got to be a good and
generous person then create that Network
that is going to be supportive of you
good times and bad
I think the I think the biggest thing I
would leave with is something I've been
spending a lot of time on is just stop
judging yourself everybody else is doing
it for you already I mean it like you
need to get past that part if you're not
in that right place
you got no [ __ ] shot you can listen
to Vice all [ __ ] day you know you've
got to stop judging yourself everybody
else sucks it [ __ ] - and not to
attenuate this but I'll share one other
thing one other thing and it has a lot
to do what you are saying but I'll say
it better anyway but much more winded
but anyway the but what what detachments
an important word and there's a thinking
in poker that if it's your life savings
in the middle of the table you're done
right you're just done it's got to be
bits of plastic right and if you don't
have that to Pat the attachment then
you're just you're just you're just done
it does it's a really interesting point
like it's funny - thank you for that no
it is it is a super I will say this it's
a super interesting point it's
unbelievable how unemotional I am about
business for all my energy and
everything that you think about like
it's I'm completely numb to it all like
if somebody screws me or this is a
matter I lose or like it's just I think
the detachment is such a variable in to
why it works for me it's just I don't
feel it that way I think it's it's the
cost of entry to play this game and
that's why I think there's so many fake
entrepreneurs right now and why I'm
nervous an entrepreneur likes getting
punched in the mouth and that's a very
different mindset
yeah and just because I've got to get
the last word but well technically I'm
going to get the last word but you know
you're right a lot of people revenge us
right lose the revenge thing people are
gonna screw you and you know what you
just got to move on and you just because
it just wasted emotion and it's gonna
happen right you know guys are just
gonna they're just gonna [ __ ] you they
just real
so we have bread bot in the back which
is automated autonomous bread bakery
let's give a huge round of applause
friend Kacey Adams right dude so you
guys take care of my secret
you